- Des voitures à perte de vue
quittant Marioupol,
ville assiégée depuis trois
ininines, bombardée nuit
et jour. 80 % de la ville a été
détruite, selon les autorités
locales.
Partir lorsesesesest encore
possible pour ne pas périr
sous les bombes.
VADIM BOYCHENKO,
maire de Marioupol
- "Le otototot pour décrire
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
est "génocide". Génocide de
notre nation, de notre peuple
ukrainien", dit le Maire de
la ville.
Lueur d'espoir, au lendemain
du bombardement du théâtre de
Marioupol : des survivants ont
été dégagés cocococombres.
Et les Ukrainintntntntinuent
de résister. Dans ces images de
la gare nationale d'Ukraine,
ce blindé russe marqué d'un "Z"
a été touché. Un homme en sort
et prend la fuite.
Les frappes russes ont aussi
touché une piscine municipal
de la ville. Des civils,
des femmes et des enfants,
s'y étaient réfugiés.
AUGUSTIN AUGIER, chef de mission
Médecins Sans Frontières
s s s s s nouvelles aujourd'huit
surtout particulièrement
préoccupantes pour les civils
qui sont dans la ville de
Marioupol. Aujourd'hui, nous
n'avons pas accès à la ville des
y aller. Nous ne pouvons pas
envoyer de matériel médical et
chirurgical. Nous ne pouvons pas
évacuer les blessés.
- Les besoins à Marioupol et
ailleurs dans le pays sont
criants.
- C'est des personnes qui sont
dans des abris et des personnesu
ou de nourriture. Des personnes
qui cherchent à obtenir de
la nourriture, de l'eau par
n'importe quelle source, quece e
soit à l'extérieur, que ce soit
en collectant les eaux de pluie,
si jamais il pleut.
- Dans ce hangar de la Croix-
Rouge internationale, on
décharge l'aide humanitaire,
des kits de chirurgie de guerre
ou de précessité.
Une aide bienvenue. Mais del'le
la Croix-Rouge, il est de plus
en plus difficile de l'acheminer
vers les villes assiégées.
FLORIAN SERIEX, Comité
international de la Croix-Rouge
- Les parties au conflit n'ont
pas trouvé d'accord concret pour
faciliter une sortie massive de
la population de la ville. Donc,
quand on parle d'êtr
concrets, on parle de choses
de manière très pragmatique,
d'horaires de route, du temps
qui va être offerteseseseseseses
pour quitter la ville.
- Dans les endroits vraiment
assiégés aujourd'hui, la seule
pepepepepepepeut faire, c'est
être prêts. Si la situation
évoluait, qu'on pouvait avoir
accès ou que les gens pouvaient
sortir, les blessés viendraient.
- Partout dans le pays, le ciel
est sombre. Les villes se
réveillent sur des colonnes
de fumée et se couchent
sur des incendies causés
par les bombardements.
Comme tant d'Ukrainiens,
cette femme pleure un être cher.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.